un golpe de estado tras otro en burkina
fasos sumiendo al país en la
incertidumbre acontecimientos que no
tranquilizan al resto del continente el
presidente de la unión africana pide el
ces inmediato de la violencia con la
esperanza de que las elecciones previas
para 2024 se celebren y devuelvan la
democracia al país el presidente Pide a
los militares que se abstengan inmediata
y totalmente de cualquier acto de
violencia o amenaza contra la población
Civil las libertades públicas los
derechos humanos y el estricto respeto
de los plazos electorales para el
retorno al orden constitucional antes
del 1 de julio del 2024 la Unión Europea
también lamenta la situación la revuelta
pone en peligro los esfuerzos de la
comunidad económica de los estados de
África occidental por avanzar hacia la
transición la Unión Europea pide que se
respeten los compromisos adquiridos que
constituyeron la base del acuerdo
alcanzado con la cdao el 3 de Julio para
acompañar a burkina faso hacia el
retorno al orden constitucional amasar
dar el primero de julio del 2024
algunos en Waka tuku celebraron la nueva
toma de poder tras la destitución del
teniente coronel de amiba
llevamos mucho tiempo esperando este
golpe estamos felices con este golpe
quien tome el poder ahora debe
estabilizar realmente el país sabemos
que los terroristas no se Irán en un día
pero Esperamos que trabajen para
erradicar La amenaza
pero otros de advierten de la
inestabilidad en burkina faso
un golpe de estado nunca ha sido bueno
para un país pero no sabemos Qué hay en
el Horizonte
queda por ver ahora dónde llevará este
golpe de estado continuará el camino
hacia la democracia según lo previsto y
cambiará el país de socios para luchar
contra La amenaza yihadista o seguirá El
ejemplo de Mali